venezuela should possibly be one of the
richest countries in the world
as opposed to really poor
you have some massive disparity between
the house and have nuts and what's
happening is they have not
it's now rising to such huge numbers
sort of a breakdown of public order on a
massive massive scale
[Music]
we went to a 400 bed hospital and
there was 170 people in there and
they had no medical supplies
they have virtually no supplies of blood
no supplies of oxygen virtually no
supplies of medicine they can't carry
out operations at all
people go there ill and are cared for
but they're not actually treated in any
shape or form
in somewhere like an oil-rich country to
go there and see that hospital
and see what people were living like it
was
horrendous
[Applause]
you're dealing with an angry population
people who are frustrated don't have
anything to lose
[Music]
it's very hard to read a situation when
you turn up you don't know whether
people are
pro-government anti-government it takes
a little bit of time to really work out
where you are what's happening get
delayed land
it can be pretty nerve-wracking
in many places if you're a journalist
you're covering insurrection and you're
watching
rioters and the right people you're
somewhat removed from it
in venezuela everyone on the street is a
potential
enemy and therefore a potential target
for them
[Music]
it's a riot situation where police are
firing
shotgun even if it is just pellets it's
still very very dangerous
they were all tooled up ready to go body
armor on
everybody had a lot of firearms
and they were very very aggressive
the protesters themselves of course are
dangerous too
they're carrying molotov cocktails
they're throwing them they have a
tendency to drop them they have a
tendency to not throw them far enough
they have a tendency to throw them
and they don't go to where they thought
they were going they actually come
towards you
all of a sudden then there were there
was a cry go up
they're coming they're coming we start
to hear people shout
and then almost like a movie i could
hear motorbike engines revving
really revving boom boom boom they were
here they came and you just knew the
police were on their way and
that at that moment just as the tension
started to rise
cs gas canisters just started dropping
around us and they came
thick and fast
before it comes to tear gas and then a
national guard arriving they're carrying
shotguns causes chaos people running in
all sorts of different directions
[Applause]
they're coming from all over the place
is going to go on all day it's going to
be more and more violence
it's very very tense now
when you get a face full of cs your eyes
start running
uncontrollably there's this horrible
feeling up inside your nostrils and
inside of your mouth and down your
throat
very very unpleasant and there was a lot
of it and
it caused a great deal of confusion and
the crowd just started to stampede and
we went with them
we got to the end of the road and we
were all sort of
hanging around on the corner now very
hot sweaty
eyes stinging from tear gas
things had calmed a little bit we were
just by the church
um everybody seemed to have got
themselves a little more composed
it was at that point stuart and i
decided to do a piece of camera
no sooner did i pick the camera up to uh
start filming
then everybody started to run the whole
place just
started sprinting and there's this huge
group of police on
massive motorbikes tearing down the road
towards us
those are questions
there's a battle going on there's this
mental battle taking place in your head
if these guys get close to you you know
they're going to be aggravated by the
fact that you're pointing that camera at
them
i knew that shot that was the shot we
needed i knew it
that for me would be the shot that
explained how scary that is because
there is no escaping motorcycles at
speed driven by experts
and they're coming over whatever is in
front of them they're going to get to
you
[Music]
there's this little angel on my shoulder
trying to pull me that way to
to get away you're just trying to test
yourself almost see how long you can
hold that shot
[Music]
gustavo our producer so we won't be able
to get away from here they'll move too
quickly
i look back sure enough they're
basically honest already
gustavo and richie both have their
cameras not up but being held in a
position with
you know they're filming but you can't
really tell they're filming
we all stood still
hands up in the air helmets off it was
pretty scary at that point
first few went past and then this guy
and i i couldn't actually believe he was
he was doing it but
he uh just lowered his shotgun
and then you just let her shot go
you're right oh
very very intimidating we had to put our
hands in the air they're still fired at
us
our producer's been hitting the arm
as you said it's happened before it'll
happen again
it's very brave they really are
hardcore playing for keeps they're gonna
suppress this demonstration
at any cost
[Music]
you're actually trying to show what's
going on
why are people actually writing on the
streets
[Music]
what they're saying is the government
isn't listening to what we say
we haven't got any money to go and buy
food and we've had enough
[Music]
and that could be from venezuela now or
the arab spring in 2011 in egypt or
in homs in syria it is people actually
standing
to the government saying you're not
doing what we think is fair
[Music]
freedom we want freedom
we don't want maduro maduro go to cuba
get out of here freedom liverpool
national or national
[Applause]
venezuela
[Music]